Have you ever wondered about the relationship between a number
Drowned in swimming pools every year
How many Nicolas Cage films in the same year?
Or what about a 99.26% relationship between divorce rates in Maine,
And between the rate of individual consumption of industrial fertilizers?
Or the 99.79% link between spending on science, space and technology
And the number of suicide bombers hanging, or suffocation, or suffocation?
The mere existence of a link of a kind between two events does not mean
That one reason for the other.
This assumption is a logical fallacy.
We are also deceived by such headlines
"Those who have sex more are making more money"
Unfortunately, "this" does not always equate to "that".
Also, there seems to be no potential relationship between cheese consumption,
And the number of dead suffocated under the quilt of their family.
However, this is sometimes unclear.
Various studies have found that women who live in menopause and follow hormone therapy
They are less likely to have heart disease.
Making doctors believe that hormone therapy may protect against heart disease.
But when a sample of women is subjected to a controlled randomized trial
He found that hormone therapy actually doubles the risk of heart disease.
Finally, when re-analyzing the original data, they find
That women undergoing hormone therapy are of the social class,
They practice a healthy diet and exercise.
This was the real reason for their low risk of heart disease.
In another case, it was found that those who slept at night under the lights in their childhood, more prone to problems of myopia.
But in fact there is a strong correlation between parents' short-sightedness
And the presence of the same symptoms in the child, the fact that the parents are short-sighted more inclined
To leave the lights of their children's rooms lit.
These are examples of the "hidden or third variable" when we find that "A" does not cause "B"
But we find "C" causing them together.
It's like talking about people with lung cancer
"Well, they all have lighters in their pockets
Therefore, lighters must cause cancer "
Without realizing that smoking is a dispersed or hidden variable.
Scientists are doing their best in their studies to avoid this.
But the situation is getting worse when the media exploit these potential random relationships.
In a study about the relationship of chocolate to weight loss was found
The ability of scientific reports to raise curiosity and interest.
A PhD in microbiology has done a real clinical trial
In which participants were grouped into three groups.
The low calorie diet team, the low-calorie diet team with a piece of chocolate (weighing 42.5 grams)
The third team retained its usual protection.
Three weeks later, the chocolate team was the biggest weight loser
But journalists use science badly.
The author tested 15 participants and studied 18 different measures, including weight loss
Cholesterol, sleep nature, blood pressure, happiness ... etc.
When you study a small number of people while measuring a large number of things
This ensures that you obtain meaningful statistical results
A topic that we have addressed in a fun clip on our Veritasium channel if you would like to see it.
The result can easily vary
Such as chocolates are associated with lower blood pressure, for example.
And if the study was reviewed by other scientists
These results can then be announced.
Instead, it was published in a magazine worth 600 euros
Fabricated the name of a false institute
"Institute of Diet and Health".
He then sent a press release to dozens of media bulletins.
In a nutshell, the headline "Be graceful with chocolate" is the front page
However, we can not get rid of the bond altogether.
Related evidence is an important part of science
Because double blind trials are not always possible and immoral.
Sometimes the link is the most appropriate guide available
When each causal relationship is systematically investigated.
Linking can be used as an effective tool for assessing cause-effect relationships
And to develop more and more science.
Tyler Vigen is very thankful to tell us his plan for these important connections
You can see his site or his book "False Interconnections" for more specific examples.
And do not forget to subscribe to more scientific sections every Thursday. Translation: team translate @autrjim